cuz I told y'all this team is cooked
y'all thought I was crazy they got away
last year because Steph went crazy in
game seven Sacramento should have beat
them they you know did two different
things no know I'm saying and with
Candace Point Steph he gon to start
slowing down too they got a old team
everybody slows down looks like he's
people forgot last year Sacramento went
there they was like they going to win
game six at home Sacramento went in
there and kicked their butt then I said
man Sacramento I picked him to win that
series but Steph went crazy he's not
going to be able to continue to do that
because those other guys aren't the same
either they're older this team is cooked
they're not a contender and everybody I
was like dude it's nothing personal just
like last year when clay went crazy on
me I said dude I love clay Clay's not
the same guy draymond's not the same guy
Wiggins has never been that guy and then
you factor and Steph has already been
hurt this year and one thing I know
about old people they just get older
they don't you older people don't they
wait Steph Curry is not playing anywhere
that looks like he's slowing at all like
at all not even close when you start
getting hurt and he's been hurt the last
couple years that to me is when guys
that's when you know age starts taking
over cuz when you're young you never get
hurt but the last couple years you're
like oh he's got these Nicks and
but the problem is he can't make up all
the other flaws Golden State 8 and N
kings are N9 and six me disagree they
will I'm working hey Adam lco
congratulations you go we get we'll get
to that well you didn't tell you didn't
even mention his name on the Tweet we
what they call it now
X